thank you very much for the invitation
I do realize some of you have seen that
talk before looking at you if you want
to have a nice walk with the weather
feel free and anybody has a lot of
apologize for giving that same talk you
before so I'm gonna talk about
incentives and games in large-scale
mobility and the first thing I'd like to
do in in this assuming the slides are
going to show is to talk about a general
framework for traffic operations that is
I think an underlying frame for what
we're doing here and then it will bring
me into inference and games so I always
like to start this talk with this
picture I even stole from Richard
Murray's controls book at Caltech which
is what every undergrad learning control
probably sees first and which is a very
good frame of many systems that we're
trying to control and then trying to use
that frame to walk through the modeling
and control of the transportation
systems we do try to explain in each of
the blocks what you know almost half a
century of contributions have led to and
where that brings us today so starting
with the systems dynamics there is
literally almost half century of
modeling of these kinds of phenomena
that have manifested itself by we just
did a quick inventory there's 900
articles in the last three decades or
four decades on PD models just for
freeways and the numbers for articles is
even larger so there's a lot of the vast
amount of models to rely on what's
interesting is when you look at the
sensing infrastructure for sensing these
systems were we've been for many many
decades in a situation where only a very
tiny proportion of the network is
actually instrumented mostly because you
know deploying things like loop
detectors of camera is costly and it's
nearly impossible to cover all of the
network leaving the transportation
network as a very ill measured and
sparsely measured system and if you
think about the control infrastructure
is not much better in that think about
controlling traffic at
scale of a corridor or a scale of a city
obviously you have traffic lights and
city streets you have maybe some more
advanced ways to manage Lane by Lane
traffic in intelligent corridors you
have metering lights and that's pretty
much all there is and so if you take a
place like the I to 10 corridor were
currently operating in California just
to manage the mobility of hundreds of
thousands of people who go through this
corridor every day in both directions
the total number of assets is 450 which
is extremely tiny and you can imagine
that it's pretty insufficient to manage
mobility efficiently and that's a
reality of most of the traffic planners
and traffic operations engineers in in
the US and in many places in the world
now when it comes to building a
controller there's two key ingredients
which have radically changed over the
last decade and will continue to change
over the next decade mostly due to the
explosion of the cellphone industry and
that have led to interesting situations
that are currently making the system
pretty unstable so first thinking about
estimation the process of estimation of
traffic is the process of understanding
the current state of the system given
the sparse measurements one has which in
traffic engineering is often represented
in the form of time-space diagram which
you can view it as a picture which over
time depicts the level of congestion
along the freeway for the stretch of
road you're interested in and so that's
called nowcast and then in terms of
demand forecasts there's little data
available or at least until a few years
ago but what you're looking at here is
essentially a prediction of what people
will the amount of people that will come
into your network so something like a
curve that shows you the morning peak
and then the evening peak and that's
mostly based on or historical data or
data collected at a few places where you
can measure this this usually is fed to
some form of optimization so traffic
engineers trying to make traffic flow
better which you could
graphically encode this as trying to
make everything green flow reality is
obviously very different and that is
usually fed to human because in almost
no places in the world will the
infrastructure at this point be operated
automatically so at the end of the day
there's a bunch of recommendations made
to people in the traffic comment centers
and they use these recommendations to
operate the system and this is two
snapshots of the d7 headquarters in Los
Angeles and the LA metro headquarters
also in Los Angeles which are the two
organizations in charge of the LA
traffic and the system that they're
running is a system we're currently
building for them and that will be
launched fully in 2019 so one thing
which is interesting here is that in
general I mean for people thinking about
optimization do you think about a
feasible set and the real question is
what you can do with the system and so
when it comes to the world of operations
one of the important thing is that you
don't have an infinite feasible set and
that there's very few things that the
different jurisdictions in charge of the
space and the infrastructure will let
you do and so typically the way things
are done in practice is whoever is in
charge of that jurisdiction writes down
a concept of operations which you can
view as the feasible set of playbooks
that are admissible by the practitioners
in charge of that ecosystem and so
essentially it's a long document which
in the case of the I 210 our team wrote
which presents all the possible thing
that the different cities in charge of
that corridor will accept such as for
example if there is a major accident
with a truck going over the rail line
using an on-ramp to make traffic exit
the freeway which is not a typical mode
of operations I guess of a freeway and
so I think what's interesting
historically is that the way these
systems have been run over the I would
say last half century is with very
little data and I think what the last
decade has brought is a lot of available
information which initially has been
used really well and which with the
emergence of routing apps as a
predominant tool for motorists to guide
themselves through the network is being
very radically disrupted so starting
with demand and forecast which is
essentially what you would want to
operate your network the disruption the
major disruption we're seeing happening
now is the fact that cellphone companies
for example like AT&T nowadays have up
to 40 percent of the population in some
states for example in California and
what that means is that because they
have access to all these cell tower
records they can know the approximate
location of forty percent of the
population in real time within 400
meters or half a mile which is roughly
the accuracy that you can get from
triangulation or trilateration and
what's really interesting about this is
that even though that data is not
publicly available and that you know
there's some proper institutional
interfaces that are needed to use that
data such as sidewalk labs and others
what it's currently doing is its
enabling the mpos and the public
organizations that are in charge of
modeling that demand to completely
change the accuracy at which they are
operating because you can write simple
problems such as OD origin destination
inference in the form of convex programs
which are fairly simple
they have gigantic null spaces but
they're fairly simple and then code the
potential routing of the different
agents in the network and essentially
that provides a sense of what the demand
on the network is so let me show you
what the data looks like to give you a
sense so this is what you see in blue is
a bunch of trajectories of a few
vehicles collected from AT&T
CDR records and then one of them in
particular is outlined here that's an
example of a vehicle traveling through
LA you can see the location is pretty
inaccurate because at some point is
talking a cell tower that is off the
freeway but the point is if you're doing
demand estimation that's good enough
because what you care about is you care
about aggregate demand from some
geographies to some other geographies
and that is data that is that is well
suited for this this is another example
of a FedEx truck that is doing a lot of
pickups and deliveries that's someone
commuting to work stopping in the middle
and so on and so forth and what's very
interesting about this is that until
recently the only way for public
agencies to access that type of demand
was to essentially use census data so
actually we're talking a lot about the
census these days in the news as many
I've heard and the problems associated
with it
and so typically the way you would get
access to demand information is by
knocking on people's doors and asking
them where they work where they live
when they commute and so on and so forth
and that entire way and for example the
scag model in California in LA has been
built on that kind of data and with
these new types of inference problems
you can solve there is really the hope
that one can really bypass and and
leapfrog the state-of-the-art using
census data and to give you a sense of
what the type of things that can be done
is that obviously these are problems
which are very ill posed because they're
not spaces are fairly large but if you
do plot the type of parameters that you
would want to see and doing this
inference then you can show that
accuracies can be pretty good so for
example when you go to a given location
and you query your phone it usually
gives you one two three four routes
maybe so if you limit the number of
potential routes that people could use
from one location to another two three
well then the accuracy you might get
depending on the grid and the Gurner
arity of the spatial data you get might
not be that good but if you actually
increase this number of rap so allow for
more options then you can get two really
good accuracies with sort of the
pointers dead here with a tessellation
of the space that is pretty relevant for
what you have in LA which is roughly
shown here about 1,000 towers per
location we're looking at and so the
high-level point I'm trying to make here
is that that's very important
so here the run we're doing is to assess
the accuracy is we use synthetic data to
to assess the accuracy because otherwise
we don't have a travel model and feed it
into the model and then obviously we see
similar convergence plans with the real
data but the real data we can't like I
says because we don't have ground truth
so so that's for a demand and state
forecast for state estimation over the
last decade we've seen a lot of
disruption of what's happened in the
field just because of the emergence of
GPS data and so going back to that state
space diagram I'm showing here typically
in order to have a good sense of what
traffic look like what you would want is
you would want to have a colored
space-time diagram like this in which
for each time and each location the
color indicates the level of the speed
so just assuming for the sake of the
explanation that initially you have no
data if you were able to measure data
along loop detectors at fixed location
what that means is that for all these
black lines here you would be able to
measure the number of cars going through
the given point that's a flow and if the
sensor fails then you don't have data
it's also except maybe in places like la
usually you can initialize a model at
midnight by assuming that the level of
vehicle on the freeway is pretty small
and the revolution which has happened
with the emergence of this of the cell
phone is that using the terminology of
Antrim on all Sciences you can actually
do like Ranjan sampling which is if you
can track a vehicle through its GPS
location you can essentially measure the
speed of the vehicle along the freeway
from which you can infer a few things
not flow but you can infer other
parameters of the models and if you
cannot track the vehicle but just
identify that specific locations like
with fast track or if you have super
super low frequency GPS then what you
know is that the value that this car is
the same as this car and so part of the
contributions that we made
over the last ticket in this field is
essentially coming up with a lot of
inverse modeling algorithms that enable
the reconstruction of this surface and
it turns out that we know since 1968
that the surface so if you view this as
a 3d plot is the solution to
hamilton-jacobi equation it's something
that was discovered by an engineer
called Colin Moskowitz at Caltrans it's
kind of visionary at the time this is
why the variable in the house and Jacobi
has named em in most comets and so
essentially what you're what you're
saying by by this is that the underlying
dynamics of that system in that diagram
I showed before
is this hamilton-jacobi equation and so
doing inference here is essentially
saying that you're sampling that
function at a given location if you're
using loop detector data that you can
initialize the value of the function if
you have an assumption of what traffic
is like at midnight when the flu is
nearly empty and that looking at the
models that function is constant along a
trajectory assuming that you can ignore
people passing each other which again is
an assumption that sometimes is valid
sometimes isn't but then provides you an
either line of the function and if not
at least the fact that this car being
the same as that car says that the
function is the same and so a lot of the
work that we've been doing in this field
over the last 10 years is essentially
coming up with inverse modeling
algorithms that can provide estimates of
the value function of that
hamilton-jacobi equation which we all
know is nasty because first it only has
a weak solution and even that weak
solution is not well behaved it's
depending on the on the framework you
use it can be as bad as lower semi
continuous which is not even continuous
function but the beauty of the framework
is that one of the things we're able to
show is that if you assume that all the
data you're dealing with is a piecewise
are fine which is for practical purposes
very good because you just make the
discretization small enough then you can
show the existence and uniqueness of
solution to the problem you can even
compute the solution explicitly and you
can formulate the problem of inverse
modeling as convex programs which was a
big contribution when we found this out
that was based on the first book we
published six or seven years ago and
we're now writing the second part with
all the different other problems we
could solve with it in particular
controls problems so to give you a sense
of what these methods look like in
specific cases we were able to collect
super high frequency data this is an
example of three second sample GPS data
for collected for 2% of the population
so it's like low density but very high
resolution and 2% I mean just that's
only a few of us in this room carrying a
phone there would be enough and what I'm
going to show is that if you apply these
methods on an even more degraded subset
like this one you can essentially
reconstruct with these convex programs
the actual value of the function quite
accurately and so for this one we had a
lot of ground truth data also collected
from video data and therefore we're able
to show that these methods are performed
really well so the interesting part is
that if you look at the historical
evolution or the penetration of
smartphone in the population these
problems were really interesting to
solve when only a few percent of the
population were carrying them nowadays
major access providers have up to
hundred percent coverage because between
for example if your Google between
people carrying an iPhone and running
Google Apps and people having an Android
essentially they can access to nearly an
entire populations data so in a sense
the inference problem is maybe not so
relevant anymore but what's interesting
with it is that from that resulted a
situation in which now traffic
information has become a liquid is and
that first trend started essentially in
2008 when these very first phone were
emerging and nowadays everybody has this
type of information for free on their
phone all the time
and so the question I'd like to address
next is what can be done with this
information let me fast forward a little
bit and show you just an example of what
that data looks like this is an example
of 500 vehicles sampled every 30 seconds
in
Sisco and what you can see is that if
you let that data play this was from the
very first system we built in this field
if you let that data play after a while
you'll see you can trace the entire map
and just to give you a sense of the
scales the last time I saw numbers of
lyft and uber drivers register for San
Francisco the number of vehicles I saw
was 40,000 I believe so you can imagine
the skills at which that data exists
today and so the next question I'd like
to tackle is you know all these problems
of inference essentially have been
fairly well studied I think it's a
fairly mature field in which we've been
very active for the last ten years and
now the question is what can be done
with that data and is that necessarily
good and that brings in to the other
topic of the talk which is games and
routing so think about the process of
how anybody who is using a router
whether it's Google whether its ways
whether it's lifts internal routers
whether it's in rigs whatever you're
using essentially you're pinching a
origin a destination and usually it's it
gives you three routes which are the
three top routes and in general the
weight selects time is that it will give
you a preferential route and it will
give you two routes for which the travel
time is not too different and so what
that does to the dynamics of the system
is that it essentially adds a feedback
loop into the plant because models for
this have been known for a while
routing patterns of people have been
known for a while and I have not evolved
fast historically until that information
became available but if now you have
hourly by hour or even minute by minute
information that will drastically affect
the speed at which you're making
decisions and obviously the main problem
with that is that the control
infrastructure is not able to adapt to
this because this is moving much faster
and this might seem a bit of an academic
problem just presented like this but
it's something which is very real and I
just would like to show you a few news
items over the last 18 months that that
we that we collected to give you a sense
of the scale of the problems this is
actually creating and so the beginning
of the story is the statements made by
elected officials with some companies
stating that you know if you give
everybody free information
which is allegedly optimal for them
you're improving Society and I can see a
lot of people doing game theory already
laughing that means you probably
understand what's coming next
what's coming next is that people start
to realize the inconvenient
externalities if you will of this type
of information on the specific traffic
patterns in their neighborhood which by
the way might not be bad if you look at
global optimum outcome of the process
but certainly not good locally and if by
the way you have seen a lot more traffic
in your neighborhood you're not alone as
you can tell from all these headlines
which I'm going to keep flashing through
getting to an interesting point here is
that at some point people started to get
really fed up of this which led to
interesting outcomes such as trying to
resist so first it was kind of funny
that at 18 months ago you started people
seeing people in news waving you know
sienten shame on you for going through
my neighborhood okay that's a bit
anecdotic all until people started to
get more organized and posting fake
detour signs to confuse people paying
senior citizens to carries phones
running the app along the street hoping
to spoof the learning algorithm that
computes travel time that's an
interesting and creative way of doing
this in fact there are manuals on how to
spoof apps you can find them on the web
it's and then the resistance gets even
more organized this is an example in
Fremont in which a city starts to UM
purpose changing the cycle terms of the
traffic lights to prevent people from
leaving the freeway so that creates a
huge backlog on the freeway so that
people don't come into their
neighborhoods so that's now interesting
because this is under sense steering the
system away from what could be more
optimal locally and then ultimately
people making that traffic even worse by
building obstacles along the road so
street bumps slows traffic stop signs
slow traffic and that's a reality of
everyday city planning today to resist
these influx of people that are coming
to neighborhoods they would never have
come to have they're not had that
information before and so that so
there's a lot of different creative
things down here
I think the main interesting point is
that obviously this might really lead to
much more much bigger legal issues and
we already start to see the first
lawsuits ironically they happen in
Israel where waste was born so it's kind
of interesting return to the source but
we might really see some class actions
in the US and not so long and so the
real question that these is asked here
is you know is the information you're
providing to people improving things and
obviously for anybody who's studied game
theory will know it to not be the case
except it's it's really hard to find
good models to do this and this is part
of the work we're doing now so just to
give you a sense of the extent of the
problem today this is where we have seen
these news pop up in just the popular
media over three minutes okay
late if I can any go [ __ ] to five okay
so this is an example of where we see
these are these things happening in the
news you can imagine it happens in many
other places if it's just bad enough
locally to make it into the news and so
let me give you an illustration of
what's happening here this is a
simulation it's not a theoretical result
but what it's what we are showing here
is a situation in which nobody had the
information so this is you could see
this as what would have happened ten
years ago and in situation in which
twenty percent of the people are using
the information so this is one minute
clip what you will see here is first
traffic accidents as a daily routine of
this Khoi door leading to immediate
backlog on the freeway that's also
fairly common if people have the
information then people reroute pretty
intuitive as well as opposed to just
staying on the freeway not knowing and
then what happens when people reroute is
that there is a chain of events that
essentially lead to the system to
operate at much worse condition and it
would be had people had not the
information and so typically first what
happens is that the residual congestion
clogs the freeway even after the
incident is cleared
that creates even more traffic in the
freeway so that's interesting how now
the value of information becomes really
negative and then what you will see in
the next few minutes of the few seconds
of the movie is that after that all this
traffic which is rerouted on the
arterial streets makes it even worse
there just because this streets are not
designed to support that extra traffic
and the single timing plans that the
intersections are also not timed
properly to react to this and then the
movie goes on and on and you can see
these chain of events and so since I
don't have a lot of time to finish maybe
I can just finish by showing one model
that which is a static model which is a
which is a model we've used to to
characterize this and in this model
which is an ash stackelberg model the
type of curves that we're producing can
be summarized like this so what what
happens is you very simple toy example
in which we have demand from here to
here and with the percentage of people
using the app by solving a simple Nash
stackelberg problem in which you assume
that you have leaders who have the
information and followers who don't have
the information and rub themselves
selfishly what you what you can compute
is the travel time on the freeway which
is what people would have done had they
had if they had not that the information
at 0% and then as more and more people
get the information the flow start to
deviate onto the first route here and
then you can see the travel time
increasing and then after a while then
it gets so bad that they start to
deviate on the second route here and
that's the second increase until the
travel time equalizes and obviously
that's the definition or that's a
manifestation of a Nash equilibrium
at which point there is no incentive for
anybody to deviate from their situation
because whatever you do if you deviated
you would be worse off and so the way
these problems are solved is typically
we have shown that for parallel networks
if you post the Nash Stackelberg problem
with a latency function that is one are
quickly increasing the same framework
customer of Gordon did with avatar owes
almost 10 years ago for the Internet
then the
or contracts and then we can solve them
and some specific cases in polynomial
time in the number of links so I'm going
to stop here because otherwise we'll be
out of time but the maybe the takeaway
message here is that when you look at
the statements made by elected officials
specific to the optimality they're wrong
because obviously we all know that there
is a price of anarchy and that in except
in some very specific cases it's nonzero
so the solution that is provided by
providing people with selfish routing is
not going to lead to a global optimum
solutions but the open question that
we're working on and certainly that is
not solved in a dynamic case is how to
arbitrate because it turns out that in
fact nash allocations might be good for
a very specific subsequent sub-networks
of the of the all transportation system
for example it does do good to the
freeway obviously there's an externality
that is suffered by the cities and so
the real question here is given that
this is going to happen because we're
not gonna be able to regulate this
industry how should the arbitration
happen so that maybe the cities get
compensated for the loss incurred and
that's an open problem for which there
is no good answer to this day so that's
we're out of time I'm gonna stop here
thank you
[Applause]
see the setting up
exactly
[Music]
so there is a there is a program called
the connected cities program that ways
has been running in which they are
exchanging data with with cities it's
not so much of a traffic management
program as much as a data exchange
program but I think with some amount of
coordination in which companies
providing that routing would be able to
not give that information to more than X
amount of people at least they would get
to that point the question is for those
who don't get an optimal route how do
you compensate them for that loss and
reality has been working on that second
part of the problem quite a lot because
they for traffic it's a it's a nut which
is very hard to crack so it's not only
within one app also coordination within
apps which you can imagine is is digital
even harder because are you gonna get
Apple and Google to coordinate on things
where they're actually competing here
[Applause]